more than a decade ago a series of
Pathways appeared connecting our world
to another dimension these Gates left us
vulnerable to Horrors previously beyond
our
imagining some awaken their battle
abilities to combat the threat they are
known as
Hunters nice to be working with you guys
oh him they call him the weakest Hunter
of all mankind you're not just staying
on as a hunter because you're too
stubborn to quit it's my fault for being
so weak I'm the only one in my family
who can work and I need the money I'll
go ginu that stone statue I think it was
looking at us get down now what the hell
I don't understand what's going on I
can't hate this anymore something's
happening but what I'm going to
die no not yet I'll survive whatever the
cost no I've done everything I could to
make it this far
if I have another
chance Hunter S tell me did you have a
second
Awakening a second Awakening it's just
me no one else can see this you need to
take better care of yourself I'm worried
about you to advance or to retreat
either way let's go the equipment is
ready I've done everything I need to do
I'm going up against the boss without my
party to back me up but I have to do
this
[Music]
no way no
way what am I supposed to do I'm weak so
I get a crappy nickname I'm weak so No
One Believes In Me fine let's give it
everything we've got as long as I'm
alive I'll fight with all I have if it
makes me stronger I'll follow this rule
no matter how ridiculous it
is